impact the pandemic becoming as tangible
as it could possibly be today with the
nfl announcing the salary cap will be
182.5 million dollars per team that is a
drop of
15.7 million from what it was last year
at
198.2
but it's even more significant than that
sharing because
the drop is just half of it
a year ago before we knew about the
pandemic before we had any idea what it
was going to do we would have expected
another let's say just 10 million
increase in the cap per team if it's
just 10 million and usually it's a
little more than that that's 25.7
million per team less than what they
planned to have see that's why this is
so problematic for the teams
you build your contracts year to year
you do your restructuring year to year
with the assumption
that the cap is going to keep going up
and it had been going up about 10
million dollars per year every year and
then
not only does it not go up
it drops by 15 seven you're talking
about a huge
cap loss from what you expected versus
what you're going to have so
that's one of the big reasons why we've
already seen a certain amount of players
cut we're going to see more and more as
teams scramble to get under that cap by
next wednesday they all have to be under
182.5 and some teams are going to have
to do a little more heavy lifting than
others to get there
you know what the worst thing about this
is mike you all started this the free
agent top 100 list before i got here so
we update that thing right so i've
already updated it two or three times
today throwing some of these names in
here and there are going to be more big
names to come into this list as we go on
so this is going to be ongoing that
we're going to have to update our free
agent top 100 list because i have a
feeling mike it's going to change
multiple times a day in the next few
days
you know that was the job that always
went to the new person it didn't even
occur to me that that that miles exactly
simmons should have ended up with that
obligation this year maybe maybe that'll
be his job next year but uh yeah this
year here's another reason why the cuts
are going to be so significant and it's
going to hit the middle class of player
and that's what we've already seen and
we we saw this coming the stars are
always going to get their money
the rookies and the guys operating under
rookie contracts are always going to get
their money because it's locked in it's
baked into the cba as to what they're
going to make oh and it's not that much
money relative to the other players it's
the veterans in the middle who are going
to be squeezed and sharing i firmly
believe
as veterans get cut by other teams
and as free agents who hit the market
next week officially and realize that
the money that they thought was going to
be there the money they deluded
themselves into thinking would be
available isn't
that's when the price is going to drop
you're going to be able to get these
guys cheaper than anyone has ever been
able to sign veterans on the open market
and what that's going to cause i believe
teams to do now when they act on it's a
different issue but what it's going to
cause teams to do
is explore who's out there and how much
they could sign them for
compare that
to veteran contracts that were set in
stone that they had no intention
of messing with either squeezing the
player to take less money or cutting the
player
you're going to have i believe a delayed
reaction here a second wave where teams
go to
veteran players who otherwise would have
been completely safe and say you know
we got a guy out here
that we can get for 5 million this year
and we're paying you 10.
so uh you know you can either take six
or we're just gonna sign this other guy
for five you let us know what you want
to do now that is a very basic example
but that that's how it works and and i'm
convinced we're gonna see
guys that we thought were safe and guys
who thought they were safe who are on
the roster first day of the league year
hey i didn't get the i didn't get the
axe as the team tried to get under the
salary cap no
but the team's able to go out and get
some guys cheap and they're taking your
jobs and that dynamic to that extent i
don't think we've ever seen before and
it's going to really create some issues
and it's going to create some
unemployment that we didn't expect
when uh the league year officially
begins
yeah and two thoughts on that mike
and we've used the dollar consu as an
example on this as a guy who's going to
have to take less money i'm interested
to see how many players just go it's not
worth my time i'm going to retire or
it's not worth my time right now i don't
want to go to training camp i hate
training camp i'm going to skip training
camp and i'm gonna wait until
some guy's injured and maybe my price
goes up but at least i don't have to go
to training camp i think we might have
some of those guys too mike some of the
big name guys that just wait and and
play out let it play out over training
kick and come in maybe that first week
of the season or last week at training
camp or however that plays out but but
later and i also think you're gonna have
guys like tom brady and dak prescott was
asked about it too about recruiting
these guys to come play for him you're
going to go to a place where you want to
win a championship most guys are if if
the money is equal right and so there's
going to be again we saw it with
well exactly you're going to go to a
place like tampa if you get the chance i
agree with you yes
so you're going to go to a place like
tampa mike if you get the opportunity or
kansas city so those guys you may see a
lot of those big names go to those teams
at some point we saw with the bucks this
year right with leonard fournette some
of those guys that signed right before
the season or once the season began a b
all of those guys
dan patrick asked me an interesting
question today i was on his show which
is on after pft live on peacock every
weekday what if tom brady goes to the
buccaneers and says you know what forget
about contract restructuring extension
whatever i'll just take the bare minimum
salary this year i'll do what drew brees
did when we thought drew brees was
setting up his retirement and we still
think that was a setup to go from 25 to
1.075 that's the minimum for someone
with seven or more years of service no
strings attached no quid pro quo just
handing the team
23.925 million in cap space
what if tom brady would do that and look
he's made his money
you give the team that much just here it
is here's a gift nothing stops him from
doing it
and uh that that would and that's the
flip side of what dak prescott was
saying today about having an obligation
to help other quarterbacks think about
what that would do
for other teams in their negotiations
with quarterbacks and what it would do
to the buccaneers as they try to
negotiate with shaq barrett if shaq
barrett is making a moon shot for his
contract he wants to break the bank and
tom brady's voluntarily going from 25
down to 1.075 it creates a little
pressure
on a guy to not be perceived as greedy
and to take
a responsible amount of the cap surplus
that's left over now i think the chances
of that happening are slim but with tom
brady i mean it's not like he needs the
money he's just he's just trying to
expand his legacy to unprecedented
heights and what way to add to your
overall mystique and legend than to say
i really don't care about the money at
this point pay me 1.075 million take the
rest of that money and keep all the guys
that we need to try to win another super
bowl
that would be incredible and i guarantee
you right now i might go to vegas and
put some money down on the box if that
happens because they would be able to
sign pretty much whoever they wanted
right they'd be even better i think i
think they're going to be better anyway
but even better than what they are on on
paper what they were this year so
mike that would be unbelievable for that
to happen and for drew brees to pay play
for that too if he decides he's not
going to retire and is going to play for
1 million either one of those scenarios
to me would just be incredible
and think about it the saints need it
far more than the buccaneers do if drew
brees says i'm still going to play and
you only have to pay me 1.075 million
i don't care what's happened to his arm
over the past five years it's not like
he ever had a howitzer anyway you get
drew brees for 1.075 million you're
gonna take that and you're gonna run
with it speaking of the saints they're
the ones who need to do the most work to
get on the right side of the salary cap
they will be cutting emmanuel sanders
and quan alexander they have done
restructurings with players like cam
jordan demario davis this will continue
marshawn lattimore could have his fifth
year option salary removed completely
wiped off the books it's 10 million plus
that creates 10 million cap space and
you know what sharing what they could
still do if they wanted to
if marcus williams who was a surprise
franchise tag recipient yesterday if he
doesn't sign that
they can remove it and if they get
caught in a vice next week and they just
can't crunch the numbers they just can't
make it work no matter what they do
the the the gift
from uh
the hangover when uh
he's you know it's like the brilliant
mind the beautiful mind or whatever it
is and all the math numbers are floating
in the air if mickey loomis can't work
it out you get an easy 10 million by
simply saying to marcus williams oh you
know about that franchise tag we're
gonna we're gonna rescind it and uh
either way they'll get there the
question is what are they gonna have
once they get there you know they could
use emanuel sanders they they yeah there
are other guys that they may be parting
ways with that they could benefit from
what are you gonna have by way of a
football team if you have to let too
many of these guys go
if you're marcus williams mike do you go
in there right now and sign the deal
sign the franchise well
uh i
i'd be tempted to uh what i what i would
do before i would sign the franchise tag
is i would have my agent
contact other teams that may be in the
market for a safety and have that
hypothetical market gauging conversation
if
for some reason there were a franchise
tag safety who had the franchise tag
removed and was available next week
hypothetically what would you pay him
again that's tampering but i'd want to
know that and if i thought i could do
better
on the open market then i'd let them
rescind it if they want to but if i if i
have my agent make those inquiries
and i know that behind that door number
two
there isn't a great payday then i'm
jumping on that franchise tender amount
the and the other reason i'd hesitate is
you know sean payton's got that bill
parcells in him and i don't know that
i'd want to be marcus williams gaming
the system and hurting the saints and
keeping them from clearing that 10
million because then you still got to
deal with payton the whole year and i'm
sure peyton would not let him forget
what he did
to screw things up for the saints and to
keep them from having the players they
wanted to have
yeah you remember when the bill parcells
used to make the first round draft pick
bringing water all the time i remember
terrence newman doing whenever he needed
water parcells had him bringing water
that may be marcus williams all year
bringing sean payton water for the
entire year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports